thank you
[Music]
a drunken man poops
on a PT Cruiser good you gotta be drunk
to do that you should good which by the
way it's not a great car I don't even
see one on the streets anymore not good
cars a long time you might need to drive
to like Riverside or something it's
wrong you have to watch certain seasons
of the office to see that car yeah you
got to be doing a certain amount of meth
to be around that car oh yeah it's like
a Bakersfield kind of car yeah big
through Riverside I agree yeah Irvine
models for the car were sweet though I
love the inspiration that it drew from
Hot Rods they should have made it a hot
rod instead they made it like the sap
they made it like the Saturn version of
a hot rod like a station wagon when they
put the wood panels on oh yeah
did you dude it's gross I think you're
being sarcastic okay
I do like with panels on a car though I
[__] can't stay though like those old
school wagons with the wood panels
they're [__] safe another car that
makes me mad is a smart car
which one the family truckster you're
not a fan of that which one's that from
from uh National Lampoon's Vacation oh
that's funny dude the uh David So hates
this I don't like it the Honda Element I
think it looks like [__] of the element
yeah oh the boxy element is that because
it's reminiscent of like the Scion
generation yeah exactly toaster cars TC
I'm telling it looks like [__] the
Nissan Xterra so this cat he he
um
takes a Duke on a a part PT Cruiser as
he should as he should which is right I
think it's just a good take right it's a
PT Cruiser if you're gonna [__] on a car
that's like one of those come on man he
was drunk but then yeah so then the CEOs
who showed up the the officers who show
up noticed a natural ice beer was in the
cup holder of the PT Cruiser and they're
like oh man like this isn't just a guy
who like has good taste on cars this guy
is probably inebriated
right so that changes the conversation
[__] on his own car [__] on his own
vehicle today did he find like a zema in
a [__] in the cup holder too that one
was drinking zemas but like that phone
had a PT crew like he [__] on a PT
Cruiser as he should yeah he [__] on his
own car oh it was a natural ice it was a
natural life
um so so then the the officers are like
okay well let's interview the the um the
perpetrator even though it's his own
vehicle and it's America but it's fun
um there's it on a scale of one to ten
how drunk are you and he's like I'm out
of five I'll be honest I'm drunk
well he's honest I'm telling you but
he's out of five yeah he's I could be
drunker
he's like hey this beer hand me that 98
in the [__] cup holder right because
I'm not gonna do the breathless I'll
just tell you
so then the uh based on that response
not the 10 level how drunk are you on a
five of drunk so then based on the
response
um the officers began conducting a
sobriety test but he already said this
[__] but then they're like is he like
this
like air traffic control arm touch your
nose I am
so then they're they're conducting the
tests
part way through the man made a face of
shock he grabs his ass
he drops his pants to his ankles and
then he starts to defecate on the rear
bumper of his own PT Cruiser so he has
more [__] he had more [__]
he [__] once and then he should have got
pulled over and then he got pulled over
there that that is this [__] this is the
moment that's the one this is the
contest dude give him a [__] medal
bro
it's done I don't even know what I would
do if you're someone just started
[__] in front of me because it
smells so bad without the water oh yeah
like you're like you pull someone over
and they just start [__] just
[__] that's why you pour the Natty
Ice on it like do you turn around to
give him a little bit of like honor but
then you're like wait but you're like
okay so I gotta like yeah watch the eyes
on you at the same time what if this guy
like eight maybe like 10 000 less eggs
than you like maybe his chips don't
smell like as bad as your [__] small
they still smell bad without the water
okay the charge is what public indecency
is what's the actual formal charge DUI
so that's a good question I think it was
yeah public intoxication right driving
right
he was not driving I think I would have
just tased him
so he could just [__] more all over the
place just taser and get the rest of it
out that guy was about to assault me and
then just tase them and then throw them
in the back of the police car don't
forget to turn off your body Cam and
then yeah and he's gonna smear [__] all
over the back of your dad uh you can if
can work for the police department oh my
God they would love them
they can't uh you do what you do again
oh yeah the cops would love them
hey sides
[Laughter]
random [__] bit oh
I'm so mad about that so funny uh so
then he gets arrested he's taking the
hospital for a blood draw on the way
there he notices that the um the officer
is using his GPS he's like man I'm the
drunk one here I I have to get give you
directions on how to take me to jail you
[__] [__] that's hardcore dude this
guy's sick whoa yeah he's shot in his
own PT cruises I [__] hate this
[__] piece of [__] car but he's also
kind of dumb because then that's when
the cops usually go swim in the back
seat oh [__] yeah so while they're at
the hospital and they're drawn's blood
the man also mentioned that the nurses
were not drawing his blood but instead
said it's all beer I'm not gonna lie to
you you're just drawing pure natural
life
this guy's a chill guy good dude he
starts doing this
what a great dude so they they gave him
the death penalties
would you let that guy babysit taika yes
only drunk though not sober he was
administered uh 50 000 volts to his
Cranium
that was his last meal
what was his last meal
um he had some nuts
nugs and Jimmy chunks some 7-Eleven
burrito fish I called everyone [__]
on his way out
believe you're a cop and this guy starts
[__] in front of you you just start
crying because you're like I wanted to
catch burglars
and not deal with hey feet on the street
this is the reason why I'm not working
at the hospital and I want to be like
Denzel Washington in Training Day what
if you're corrupt hotter than him
[__] in the cruiser though yeah at
least on the pizza in his own Cruiser on
PT Cruiser yeah which is by the way if
you're gonna [__] in a car that's the
car to [__] and it doesn't sound like a
TP user
guys he [__] drinks Zima and drives
the PT Cruiser dude disguise everyone's
Uncle who got a PT Cruiser got a little
wasted
have a good night
jeez and got killed with
fifty thousand what was the worst
situation you guys had to [__] in public
him oh is it in public or like pulled
over I'm like [__] I got a [__]
somewhere there's no bathroom I was at a
um youth group thing for [__] church
and of course the bathrooms were like oh
sorry they're closed it's like they're
being blessed dropping or whatever at
church yeah I go to the woods and I just
take the fattest [__] next to a window
at the church I like to take a full
diarrhea blowouts your eyes rolled back
yeah it was a liquidation scene so
that's the problem right there was
nothing to wipe with what so [__]
ever loose nah
foreign
can pull honesty from his heart and give
it to the people
a man
does not [__] around no I I have two
hands
no I'm proudest moment
I was like 13. I like scooped the back
of my [__] like oh God and and then
with my other hand
and then I went to the water fountain
yeah two hats the water fountain elbow
elbow the water fountain clean this
butter and then elbow the water fountain
so you pulled up your pants with [__]
hands well it was dark it was dark it
would have been better if you're walking
to the water remember your thumb her
pants around your thumb hook it you guys
know how to walk let's not [__] lie
can we not lie yeah can we be friends
and not who don't mind yeah yeah I
wobbled I pulled my pants up enough to
where my shirt hung down enough and then
I wobbled my way to the water fountain
did my thoughts that's pretty gangster I
mean it looked like a Saginaw it's just
like that guy is Saturday that's kind of
like [__] sore the guy with [__] in
his hands was kind of sweet
guy with brown gloves he was just
sagging he's [__] fly when I was like
when I was a kid
um Iraq I rushed into the bathroom
public bathroom take a [__]
and then when I was done there was no
paper
and I was like [__] what am I gonna do
right the copiation room but there was
no one there was no one in the bathroom
so I I did a mission impoopsible style I
still had my pants around my ankles
right so there's two things I could have
done go to another stall whatever I just
went under oh sure
[__] crawled got to the next toilet
and realized it was a glass man there
I sat down I used that toilet paper
finished up [__] left dude
the door was locked the [__] wasn't
flushed I just left that [__]
room no
one way in
General's gonna be like what mystery
what was this accomplished oh [__]
did he go under or did he go over it's
like where did he get out of it so we
lost the kid in the toilet get out but
it's true you do walk into some public
restrooms and you're like wow
who did this and why
it's like CSI [__]
I do remember when I was a youngin
probably third grade I pooped my pants
in class I did one of those who farted
right classic until I could go to the
restroom when I went to the restroom
obviously waddling with a giant lump
coming out
[Laughter]
um it was a dry [__] it was a dry [__]
so there's nothing wet or juicy poop
your pants in third grade yeah what are
you disgusting
you were an adult you literally just
talked about like who shits all over the
wall you shat on the walls and [__]
had to tell Geo about it after you
[__] went to her house at one time
right so grown ass man that was a shower
wall he was sick hold on he had food
poisoning yeah yeah almost your excuse
he scraped it off the enamel with his
fingernail what'd you do I read crowded
that tile you sucked so bad at it that
the chicks had cereal are doing season
three on you [__] all right then
I guess I'm done with my story
yeah you like it yeah [__]
oh yeah you want to hear the rest I hate
how comfy he is now I waddled to the to
the restroom and I think to myself I'm
like all right cool at least I'm in the
safe space right
uh going to the stall and then I try to
pull my pants down but the thing is uh I
pull it down and I see my underwear and
I see a [__] steam but I don't see the
[__] oh man it's really bad we lost
control dude [__] the loose cigar
that's you five seven one that's a
Houston we have a problem where'd it go
so I'm looking around for a second then
I hear a plot and I realized it was
stuck to my ass a little bit again oh it
plops on the floor so I just hear I
don't see it right and then I don't know
why but my dumb ass at the time as a kid
what I had what I thought to do was like
I'm gonna wipe my ass or I Gotta Throw
This underwear away I can't wear this
underwear anymore I was gonna tuck right
so I had already before taking off my
pants I take off my shoes so you're
Barefoot so I got socks on mirrored the
mother yeah and then I [__] pull down
my pants I can't find it here I plop I'm
gonna turn around I step in my own
no no no so there's just a giant [__]
like dude I'm gonna throw up dude I'm
gonna throw up actually it was funny oh
my God
from there it was just like just double
crisis so I basically had to like
maneuver in the small spot threw away
that sock I threw away this underwear I
was wiping my [__] wiping my foot it
was just it was a mess it was a mess and
I fully remember every part of the
details you must have been panicking you
turned into an adult though because like
you solved that problem that's why
you're probably so mature most kids
would probably just start crying and
then just like come out of the bathroom
dude that's why you're a cool cup
t-shirt on with my dick dangling and I
would be walking out like I failed I
think I would have stuck my foot in the
toilet and try to flush the [__] out of
my shoes
they'd go in a panic mode oh yeah I
would have just had a T-shirt and one
sock on wobbling outside teacher so in
your group in your group The kinjas your
motto is fear none did you fear anything
in that moment are you actually feeling
fear is that when that was born see the
thing is I I feared nothing in that
moment but the first part of that scene
is respect all I had no respect for
myself oh that was the hardest part and
you know what when you like throw away
one sock when you're a kid
like that's like a really weird and big
deal oh you didn't throw both of them
away no because I I don't know only one
of them had [__] on it right but the
thing is like what do you ever do with
that other one sock that doesn't have
like its cousin it's a spare you know
what I mean I can't figure it out or
worried I was more worried about telling
my mom where the other sock was yeah
such stupid [__] to worry about right
it's a black sock and this is a this is
a great at least they're both I don't
know what the [__] happened
black sock gray sock I don't know what
the [__] happened same [__] once you
lose track of one it's it's over after
that it's a [__] Domino I just
remember being scared to tell my mom
that's all
[Music]
foreign